[Musique]
on est à berlin le samedi 1er septembre
ça y est enfin septembre enfin même
malheureux bon c'est le deuxième jour
officiel de voitures leaf a pour moi
c'est le dernier jour je repars demain
matin direction paris et là je vais vous
montrer un truc parce que j'ai un hôtel
qui est juste là et qui est située à à
l'endroit où passait le mur de berlin la
jonction entre l'est et l'ouest anthony
les jonctions trop vite et l'ouest et la
dernière vous avez toutes les infos bon
ça c'est fait là vous voyez 1961 la
construction le début du mur c'est
vraiment rendre fou parce que berlin tu
nous avais d une ligne qui traverse
toute la ville qui est dessiné au sol et
qui vous montre exactement l'endroit où
passait le mur et c'est vraiment
interpellé c'est vraiment compliqué
marqué d'histoire forcément quand vous
avez un petit garçon qui est pas et
grimper voilà donc c'est vraiment pas
mon truc assez dingue à berlin c'est
vraiment une super ville l'atmosphère de
dingue aujourd'hui on va faire pas mal
de choses la toute première chose je
vais vous présenter un smartphone que
j'ai pris en main que j'ai vu il ya eu
la présentation de sony du nouveau
budget de 3 c'était il ya deux jours
j'ai pu le prendre en main les séries
rencontré pas mal de monde chez sony je
vraiment partagé à vous parce que je
trouve vraiment que sony fait vraiment
des super beau et fort c'est un
smartphone qui est vraiment vraiment
magnifique
ensuite on va continuer on a pas mal de
monde à voir et on va terminer ce soir
avec une petite soirée chez qualcomm qui
ma réalité une sauterie dans un hôtel
donc on va aller voir sa troupe est
passé hyper cool ypersele ce qui a pas
de problème et voilà donc ce super
content allez pouvoir rencontrer
aujourd'hui coin comme pour parler des
snapdragon
il ya un mec qui a présenté son kirin
980 et hier donc on va voir ce que va
nous proposer un petit peu qualcomm non
c'est plutôt cool non voilà
c'est parti les gosses
voilà ce que deviennent les sapins de
noël quand tu sont abandonnés dans la
nature au mois de septembre neuf mois
après voilà bon bah je sais pas si
quelqu'un avait utilisé pour halloween
sera peut-être la faire on se retrouve
aujourd'hui sur le stand de sony
directement l'ifa ou sony vient
d'annoncer le nouveau smartphone xperia
x3 on a eu exactement début d'année que
des franchement déjà un excellent
smartphone sony elle est vraiment fait
un effort au niveau du design là avec
l'exacte 3 franchement la coupe est
qu'on aille pas me dire que sony un
design obsolète old school ce que vous
voulez c'est strictement impossible
le produit est franchement super joli
sur le dos il a des faux airs du finepix
dopé bien grave de toute façon c'est un
produit qui est vraiment très jolie vous
avez un écran oled bravia à l'avant qui
est dingue mais ça pour vous en parler
ça fait rappelle un spécialiste
on est avec ceux samir qui est directeur
marketing chez sony on a aujourd'hui une
annonce du higgs est de 3,1 produits que
ce sont en tout cas super jolie samir de
la montrer le regard d'un petit peu est
ce que ça veut dire qu'il peut nous vous
expliquer l'adn de ce produit
ce qu'on peut faire avec acquise estime
quoi comment la compacte se produit
c'est le produit pour les fans de cinéma
de série de contenus puisque c'est le
produit qui va intérêt pour la première
fois l'expérience tv bravia oled
l'objectif de ce produit servant fournir
une expérience de divertissement deux
teams et unique et ça commence par une
qualité d'image
impressionnant
voilà la ranger et moi la qualité de
cette époque sera lui aussi papa
la restitution des couleurs de
également là
c'est la clarté plus condescendant les
grands débuts
1442 1186 être ambitieux 9e congrès agir
de telle idée comme c'est le cas la
rencontre
moi je sans toi
spectaculaire pour le pouvoir puisque et
mettre à niveau le pr
avantium sur youtube
les angles de vision aussi ont été
travaillés l'écran est recoupée sur la
côte est
un produit qui est plus jeune
les adieux il conserve son design 1
voilà tout en élégance avec des
matériaux des matériaux tout en berne
le design franchement c'est vrai que
c'est un point qui évolue énormément
chez sony avec le xz-1 en début d'année
y avait déjà une très très belle
évolution
là vous aviez encore plus loin ce que je
trouve vraiment super c'est l'écran
incurvé la volonté de l'écran incurvé
c'est pourquoi profiter de l'immersion
au smartphone c'est vraiment pour les a
tuées je le digère vraiment le produit
est vraiment orienté autour de
l'expérience visuelle donc on a voulu
que l'écran prennent la plus grande
partie de la face avant
sans négliger le son puisque les haut
parleurs restant en façade et ça ça
permet d'avoir un effet stéréo en effet
enveloppant qui est super samba haut
parleurs stéréo donc parleurs stéréo sur
les deux côtés qui sont 20% plus
puissant que l'exode de hockey qu'on a
une expérience aussi audio qui n'est pas
négligée et c'est ce que je disais au
début donc on est un espace de
divertissement
couplé au système de vibration aussi est
hyper immersive et d'ailleurs sur le
stand je t'invite à tester la partie
acheter sur le côté avec plaisir pour
nous guider dans ce jeu vous occupez
ip68 recherche pour l'induction tout à
fait recharge par induction hockey
génial usb tisser type ses haut-parleurs
stéréo en termes de puissance près ce
qu'il a dans le ventre
cela bragon 845 il ya 4 gigas de ram
on a un système intelligent que c'est
pas les sparklines et/ou permettre de
bien optimisé ses 4 gigas qui sont
largement suffisants
faire de ce produit un des produits les
plus fins du marché avec la plateforme
la plus puissante aujourd'hui sur le
marché ce n'est pas connue 545 en termes
de stockage on est situé comme 64
extensible avec une carte mémoire
microsd jusqu'à 512 pour ton mais
disponible sur le marché
largement devant nous on a de quoi vous
dire quoi faire pour ses contenus
préférés justement c'est un produit qui
est intelligent aussi beau ça
un puisque en fait
le côté droit
pour dc et réagissent à 5,7
application qui n'est pas intégrée au
on perd m
actualisé personnel
de proposer à l'utilisateur ses
applications
pas de personnes en consomment sur
l'utilisateur que le moteur intelligence
intérêts
il va proposer soit des rats posé un
vrai des applications
ça va être une manière personnalisée
continue d'apporter son côté il ya un
capteur son côté sa femme exactement en
fait si les deux côtés qui sont
un question réactif il suffit d'appuyer
sur le côté
et ensuite en glissant son doigt sur le
côté bourrin
ça fait peur mais c'est tout ce retour
également parce que lorsqu'on est là
entre 12h50 sa 1re bien aussi
à l'interface possible en terme
d'expérience photo
vidéo qu'est ce que disent exode 3 sur
la photo on
toujours ce capteur motion eye 6 9 me en
pixels qui vous permet de fumer comme un
pro ce qu'on filme en 4k hdr on est le
seul à le faire devant nous quatre
caches derrière on filme aussi en super
slow motion mais en 960 images seconde
et en full hd ça aussi on est les seuls
à le faire on a également un capteur 13
millions pixels
en face à qui vous permettent de faire
des scènes fille de qualité ok voilà
côté photos et vidéos on a on a on a
vraiment des fonctionnalités uniques sur
l'ex époux sur les visages on a
entièrement refondu d'interface photo
on peut désormais accéder à la partie
vidéo avec un léger soit on a ici
différents modes notamment le mode
ralenti ici qu'on peut activer
on a
google indique et la partie ok on peut
passer en manuel et lorsqu'on veut
passer sur la partie sale fille il
suffit juste de swype est comme ça et on
bascule de l'image frontale et on a
également une fonctionnalité qui est
compliqué à voir en vidéo la main en
juste en pointant avec son téléphone
comme ça on va pouvoir déclencher
automatiquement l'appareil photo à lui
déclenché des examens de versions des
tricks exactement quand je prend son
téléphone il consulte qu'on pointe comme
ça vers un son téléphone et l'appareil
photo va se déclencher automatiquement
on appelle ça le smart launch c'est
aussi une nouveauté dans le x3 et c'est
quelque chose qui unit crise en terme de
d'os en tournoi ensuite on tourne sous
android 9 et premier à lancer avec parle
de google exactement andrei 9 bail
on est les premiers avec avec google à
arriver sur ma d'acteurs avec cette
toute dernière version d'android 799
euros
pour avoir un écran bravia oled moi je
dis on s'en tire plutôt bien
il ya disponible à partir de quand
datent du début encore début octobre on
peut l'acheter par toucher tout le monde
il sera disponible chez les opérateurs
et dans la description performance
intelligence élégance l'exode trois
exactement ok génial quand ben écoute
merci beaucoup merci à toi et puis nous
retenu au tour
[Musique]
produits franchement y perd ses 10 ans
très joli ce que sony havrais a vraiment
bien réussi sa copie produits supérieurs
au niveau des specs qui tient vraiment
bien la route au point de vue design est
extrêmement bien réussi on n'est pas le
dire comme c'est pas un produit joly
parce que cette fois ci après c'est une
question de goût les goûts et les
couleurs mais sauf que vraiment sony a
vraiment fait de l'excellent boulot là
dessus alors je vous invite à faire une
chose c'est à rester connectés à vous
voyez pas ce qu'on va parler encore plus
de sony passé en plein plein de choses
intéressantes il ya des casques
bluetooth et différents objets collectés
avec petit robot aibo que j'ai pu le
voir à directement aux crs a des gars
c'est pas très longtemps
et puis sony c'est de la télé c'est une
chose la gagne dans cinq connectés il ya
plein de choses de tous les côtés il ya
pléthore produit donc c'est plutôt
génial puisqu'on est son stand de sony
on va parler de where hebel
là vous avez des montres de montres
connecter avec non pas juste l'écran qui
vous permet effectivement vous connecter
et puis de changer votre contenu mais
également le contour le bracelet pour
vous connecter avec votre monde vous à
une petite appli vous choisissez le
design vous l'envoyez ça part et ça
c'est génial et au delà de ça ils vont
beaucoup plus loin et c'est ça qui est
intéressant ils ont en partenariat avec
new balance sais pas si vous voyez vous
avez toutes les chances sont plutôt
fischer c'est des chaussures qui sont
connectés à l'amont c'est-à-dire que
vous avez une partie du design de la
chaussure qui va changer en fonction de
ce que vous avez sur notre monde on se
permet d'avoir quelque chose de super
bien au niveau du verre est belle votre
monde change votre choses changent tout
change à leur bon pour l'instant dans
l'écho début tout ne va pas changer
mais c'est vraiment encourageant et en
tout cas je combats dans mon sens c'est
vraiment génial de pouvoir ces
innovations comme ça on va vers des
habits connecter avec la montre en haïti
maintenant on va avoir vraiment des
vêtements collectés et ça c'est génial
que l'on se retrouve dans un
excellent endroit un très joli hôtel
pour parler de quoi comme c'est un
événement qualcomm donc l'idée c'est ça
va être de discuter notamment pour la
partie 'smartphones' des snacks guidance
pour essayer de comprendre comment il
marche pour un petit peu ce qui est
arrivé et tout si tout ça voilà c'est
super cool et c est ça aussi que des
événements comme ça sont vraiment
géniaux à l'ifa j'ai eu l'opportunité de
pouvoir effectivement être invité à cet
event pour pouvoir aller rencontrer
directement les équipes qui travaillent
au développement des différents produits
de qualcomm lauria il ya beaucoup il
partie audio est aussi la femme doit
gagner c'est pas mal de choses donc ça
c'est vraiment génial n'ont réagi je
profite et puis on peut sentir la
chanson extrêmement bien reçu des
petites petites coupes à bois petites
choses à manger vivre assez c'est
formidable je trinque avoué la santé
très sympa cet événement qui m'a permis
de parler un petit peu que les équipes
de qualcomm pour essayer de voir un
petit peu ce qu'est l'espace alors pour
la partie snapdragon sur smartphone il
va falloir attendre l'annoncé au mois de
décembre
ça sera le prochain soc on est pour
l'instant au stade dragonne 845 on
pourrait avoir un sens dragonne soit 850
comme on a sur les pc soit carrément 855
pourquoi pas on est passé de 835 puis
145 155 ça pourrait s'entendre mais vous
dit pour l'instant on est à la
numérotation sur pc qui ont huit cent
cinquante ans que ça pourrait dire donc
pour la partie smartphone on va attendre
il va y avoir une annonce très bientôt
le 10 septembre aux états unis qui va
être faite sur les montres connectés
instinct dragon pour monde connecté et
puis l'accueil la partie effectivement
pour pc avec le teint dragonne 850
l'idée si vous voulez pour qualcomm
c'est vraiment de répliquer ce qu'ils
font sur smartphone c'est à dire sur le
stand dragon 850 c'est un soft qui est
gravé en 7 nanomètres qui va permettre
d'aller plus loin sur la l'intelligence
artificielle sur la compréhension sans
optimisation de la machine et notamment
sur l'économie de la batterie ce qui
fait que vous allez pouvoir regarder une
charge extrêmement longue
même lorsque vous allez avoir votre
machine qui va être allumé il va tourner
à minima en utilisant le minimum de
performance pour ensuite parce que vous
allez utiliser pouvoir carburer faire ce
qu'il faut et vous garantir une
longévité en termes de batteries
beaucoup plus longue
ça a c'est vraiment cool si on trouve
actuellement sur le stand dragon 850 sur
les ordinateurs et notamment son
ordinateur de lenovo on a donc quelque
chose qui est vraiment optimisé l'idée
c'est rendre à quelque chose de toujours
plus miniaturisés toujours plus petits
pour permettre à des marques et des
constructeurs comme lenovo qui étaient
exposés ici d'avoir quelque chose de
toujours plus fins donc des ordinateurs
extrêmement fins miniaturisés des design
qui sont vraiment super bien très
élégant très pratique avec le maximum de
puissance surtout le maximum de batterie
et de durabilité
donc c'est ce qu'on va retrouver aussi l
année prochaine sur le seul un dragon
850 sur 55 on sait pas trop pour
l'instant ça équipera les modèles de
l'année 2019 donc ça s'arrête aussi
super cool donc vous inquiétez pas on en
reparlera pour l'instant et encore un
petit peu tôt il y a
huawei est passionnante avec son kirin
980 hier on voit qu'ils ont
effectivement un socle qui gravait en
cette nano m le prochain choc de
qualcomm sera gardée pour les
smartphones dans cet anneau m et il va
aller encore plus loin pour
l'intelligence artificielle pour vous
aider à améliorer votre photo à mieux
anticiper vos besoins à optimiser votre
batterie voilà donc c'est vraiment ce
qui va se passer en termes de puissance
pour cette fin d'année à regarder moi
une jolie ferrari sur une dépanneuse
voilà c'est dommage ça arrive donc voilà
ce qui va arriver pour cette fin d'année
pour l'année prochaine c'est à dire des
machines qui va être vraiment boosté à
l'interface officielle voix de boue
séchée du malheur qui tue et c'est à la
fin de journée vous voyez un petit bouc
des machines qui vont être boostés à
l'intelligence artificielle pour
optimiser votre batterie pour plus de
performances de signer sa démesure photo
va donc ça c'est super cool pour moi les
amis l'ifa se termine
la nao maintenant je rentre demain sur
paris bonne soirée ce soir on va tester
la caméra du samsung galaxy note 9
j'en avais parlé il ya un petit moment
j'ai pas eu le temps de le faire je vais
donc le faire ce soir
j'en profite d'une partie d'une petite
soirée que le vivent comme ça on va
pouvoir voir sir faible luminosité dans
les clubs de berlin ça l'fait oui ou non
en tout cas merci d'avoir été nombreux à
me suivre sur ce trip berlinois va plein
plein plein de choses plein de contenus
publiés qui va arriver par la suite
parce que forcément l'actus s'arrête pas
là j'ai filmé plein de choses que j'ai
pas le temps de vous diffuser et puis il
ya un voyage à un milan la semaine
prochaine et pas mal de trucs donc vous
invite à faire une seule chose c'est à
rester connectés à vous abonner
[Musique]
oh